welcome to alternative New York or maybe
given its alternative we should be
alternative New York and just give it a
slightly different angle to everything
I'd like to thank our organizers my old
friends Danny finger off and Karen green
and my new friend Jeremy Dalbir for
inviting me to be part of this and for
putting together such a great collection
of talent that we've got over here as
Karen said I'm gene Canterbury jr. my
book 500 essential graphic novels came
out in 2008 and that's a book that would
look entirely different if I did it
today so much changes in four years in a
previous life I was the chair of the
international Comic Arts Festival and
the comics in comic art area of the
popular culture association in a written
essays about comics on topics from
winsor mccay to Charles Atlas parodies
go Charles Atlas I love the art form of
comics but I find the business or the
publishing in the reception that art
form all somewhat baffling are
cartoonists on this panel among them
published in newspapers across the
country and have entries in Bartlett's
familiar quotations or take it to
subjects classic works of literature or
just Chronicle the many and varied
aspects of everyday life none of that
actually seems alternative to me
alternative to what exactly maybe our
panels can shed a little light on that
fine just a introduce our panelists in
alphabetical order and there luckily
sitting alphabetical order starting from
the right we have Charles Bronstein then
if the executive director of the comment
buckle Defense Fund which is a nonprofit
organization that protects the mediums
First Amendment rights by providing
legal representation education in
matters affecting the rights of compal
creators retailers librarians and
readers no small task there in addition
to his work at the CBL DF he's written
extensively about the medium with
publications including the award-winning
books Eisner Miller and the oddly
compelling art of Dennis kitchen Dennis
was just here on the last panel I first
discovered Charles to his magazine
feature way back in the day which
probably some wonderful interviews of
many cartoonists and I've still got all
those in a box somewhere which they're
part of the permanent Annenberg
collection see the next to him is bill
Griffith a long time on the ground
cartoonist and the creator of zippy the
pinhead daily comic
Zippy's been nationally syndicated since
1986 by the first and oldest American
comic syndicate king features which is
still in New York City this makes mill
this makes bill perhaps the most
mainstream of any of this weekend's
guests given the potential size and
breadth of his readership he's on the
alternative comics panel excellent I was
lucky enough to see a gallery show of
his original zippy artwork in hudson
last year i got to in gray enjoy great
artwork and a free ding dong
fantagraphics is just published a
collection of drifts early underground
work bill Griffith lost and found comics
1969 2003 I first learned about Griffith
when zippy began being published in the
pages of the Milwaukee Journal in the
late 1980s at first I did not get it
what is this but somehow suddenly
everything snapped and I've been hooked
ever since I've tracked down all the
books zippy Quarterly's everything and I
even got to read about the comp read
about him for the comics journals top on
her to come up to the 20th century issue
and sorry it was only at number 69 I was
not responsible for the numerical
ranking of that one Arsene Coria bob was
born in the San Francisco Bay Area in
1982 and as the no he was not that this
this bob is the author of Master P's
comics drawn and quarterly it's so close
I'll also a great start as carton
illustration have appeared in The Onion
The New Yorker spongebob comics mad and
many other publications he's drawn for
the daily show with jon stewart and ugly
americans bob is talk tillis tration at
parsons the new years The New School for
Design and comics at the center for
cartoon studies up in River Junction
Vermont since 1997 he's presented his
cartoon slideshow series carousel around
the u.s. and Canada my first
introduction to his work was in raw vol
2 especially good old Gregor brown his /
his pitch perfect retelling of chacos
metamorphosis using the visual
vernacular of Charles Schulz as peanuts
genius
julia weirds was born in san francisco
bay area in 1982 and as the author
illustrator of the she posted
unfortunately titled fart party volumes
1 & 2 and the icer nominated graphic
novels drinking at the movies fart party
is now known by the somewhat less
evocative title Museum of mistakes and
she's currently at work on a book for
cuyama press due out in September 2012
and she lives in Greenpoint in Brooklyn
and probably has enough to apartment in
weeks so we're very glad to see her here
tonight I apologize I was not really
aware of fart party when it was an
ongoing thing sadly that's the trouble
with the internet there's so much out
there so I didn't actually learn about
her work until the librarian where I
work brought me an advanced readers copy
of drinking at the movies as a present
from a conference she'd gone to I was
blown away by Julia subtle but effective
manipulations of the comics format and
especially by her comic voice and timing
which are just hilarious okay our break
this afternoon was to examine both New
York in underground and alternative
comics and it's a home for underground
and alternative cartoonists that's a lot
to do in 50 minutes but if I could just
start off with a kind of a general
question for everybody on the panel just
to briefly what do you make something
alternative do you consider your art or
theme somehow alternative and if so
alternative to what why don't we start
with Charles actually the only one here
that doesn't make comics but but I've
you know spent a lot of my career
writing about and and and defending a
variety of comics and the thing that I
think binds the individuals on this
panel together and creates this
sensibility of alternative or what began
is underground is a dedication to the
authorial impulse in the work and so I
believe that if you look at comics in
the late 1960s and early 1970s when the
underground moment occurred comics were
thought of as these children's creations
these characters the superheroes they
weren't really thought of for their
authors outside of very rare examples of
the demand and strip papers and so I
think alternative tends to historically
mean that these are people that are
authors first and pursuing their
authorial vision through art and I think
today when you see a creator like Julia
or creator like Bob working in in the
media there an alternative to the more
corporatized structure of media you know
Bob is commenting whimsically on
trademark and ownership of cult of
culture when he's juxtaposing classic
characters with classic art styles that
actually belong to corporations and so
in that regard I think he's providing an
alternative to that ownership I think
Julia is an interesting full circle
because back in the day when guys like
Bill were creating underground comics
and you know lashing out at the system
the system was appalled and they started
prosecuting you know the retailers now
they're trying to buy her and take her
out to Hollywood but you know to that
degree I think you know it stands at the
binding influences you know this
independence of authorial vision that
you know ties the generations together
it makes these things alternative yeah
dope Charles just on my desk line
going to say when I did underground
comic sure could get busted for it you
actually get arrested not the cartoonist
but the distributor's the book store
clerks as a matter of fact in nineteen
seventy three and four there was a
Supreme Court ruling on pornography that
said that pornography was something that
would be determined by community
standards which was then a taken up as a
sort of a banner by by crusading DA's
trying to get reelected and they busted
underground comics coast to coast and
suddenly they were all coming back from
the from the stores and the people that
got busted were the clerks behind the
counter we as cartoonists were untouched
but kind of chilled by the whole thing
and the publishers went through a real
crisis the whole thing almost kind of
went belly-up i remember in about 74 i
started working with art spiegelman
doing wacky packages and i thought this
was going to be my new career that the
underground comics thing might be over
but it bounced back and it's managed to
survive i think except francisco
underground comics I kind of put at a
period of like 1967 to about nineteen
eighty-two something like that when I
consider it to be truly underground
after that there was another generation
that came along people like Dan Klaus
and chris ware and I think you know to
the degree that we paved the way for
them they they carried the whole thing
on and a little by little and gained
even a larger audience and I'm very
grateful for that because I wrote as
they rode my coattails I road there's
and there's always been waves of
interest to me alternative at the time
that we didn't use that word we used
underground what that meant to me was
all the comics I didn't really like we
were not them
if I remember we once had a meeting in
my house I think we were trying to
organize a union some crazy plan and Ted
Richards who you may or may not know the
name Ted Richards he did a comic book
called dope and Dan he was one of the
air pirates in the 70s he came to the
meeting with the idea that we should get
out of the underground and go mainstream
and work for King Features this was in
like nineteen seventy-six something like
that and we laughed him out of the room
ten years later I was working for key so
I've gone all the way from under to
above ground and somehow managed to
still not bow to the corporate interest
when I when I started doing zippy as a
daily first it was just in the san
francisco examiner in 1985 and will
Hurst who had kind of will Hurst the
third had inherited the paper from his
uncle the paper was failing of course
that's why he got it and he decided to
hire me crumb and Hunter Thompson I was
the only one that worked out Robert has
heart was not in it somewhere this 20 or
30 strips that he and they lean did
together full of sex and cursing which
they handed in so well and of course you
said sorry and that was the end of that
hundred Thompson I think lasted maybe
three three or four columns we went out
in a blaze of gunfire I remember and
then a year later King Features
approached me so when people ask me how
do you get syndicated how do you do
something as weird just get zippy
they've been headed into into the
Washington Post I say you work in
obscure underground publications for 15
years then wait for the phone call if
you want to hear more stories like that
you need bills new book his introduction
is just nothing but stories like that
over and over and over it's amazing it's
lots of fun Bob
well again a lot of great lines have
been said already but one thing that
certainly occurs to me is that
alternative art is generally the art
that doesn't pay and that is where a lot
of us live but what is interesting i
graduated college in the late 80s an
alternative rock was starting to happen
and then suddenly alternative rock sort
of became the mainstream and alternative
bands like REM became the biggest band
around and alternative bands like u21
the alternative Grammy in like nineteen
ninety-two it's like they were already
the biggest band and suddenly they were
alternative so these these these
definitions of what's alternative and
what's mainstream are very fluid but I
do think the authorial voice is maybe a
big part of what makes alternative
comics different than mainstream comics
which are a small portion of the
marketplace to at this point so these
lines are really blurry I've certainly
traveled from from making no comics to
some publications to making comics for
mainstream publications like the New
Yorker I don't get those as much as they
know paying jobs but they exist they
coexist and somehow alternative is this
very amorphous form that i think is
great for marketing but you know you
make the work you want to make and you
let other people you know pigeonhole you
and hopefully that does use some good
okay um yeah I'm kind of with you on
this one like alternative to my
generation just sort of means I it's
kind of a nice way I guess I was saying
that you do something that no one's
really interested in you're like oh my
that's alternative they don't understand
and we use the word ND a lot in my
generation of comics and um I mean I
don't I don't know I don't really bother
myself with wondering like in my
alternative or mainstream or indeed
because I everyone just says like I'm an
indie creator and I've worked with
mainstream publishers and my book did
not sell for them so you know maybe it
is something that should be corralled
into a small sort of population of
people doing something um I don't I
think they pretty much said everything
it just means we'll be poor for forever
well after after this afternoon big-time
big-time ething everybody here is going
to buy a copy of her book okay let's see
i'd like to provide proceed in kind of a
chronological way at first talking
concern about the venues available to
underground or alternative cartoonists
in New York from connect the late 60s
until today this will not be inclusive
but it's just a few things to get
through and then maybe even concurrently
there's going to be a little overlap
probably we can talk about New York as a
home to alternative cartoonists and the
communities and friendships that evolved
from that somebody said earlier there's
probably more cartoonists on one block
in on one Street in Brooklyn there is in
all of most other cities combined and
then we can also talk a bit about our
cartoonists their own work that was that
has been specifically inspired by New
York and then after that Charles is
going to talk to us a bit about the
ramifications of producing alternative
work those ramifications for creators
publishers booksellers and sometimes
even readers and we'll start with bill
Griffith who's like I said one of the
pioneers of the underground comics and
bill sent me several images of early new
york-based Underground's and I was kind
of hoping that you could talk a little
bit about them and maybe how you got
into comics with an X in the first place
yeah I started doing comics in late
nineteen sixty eight after having seen I
think it was Kim dyche's work in the
East Village other at first I didn't
really distinguish between Kim and crumb
believe it or not
I mean I can't believe I thought that at
one point but to me it was just wild
underground wacky stuff and it was like
saying things that I wish I had said and
drawing things I wish I had drawn I was
not doing comics I came to comics
circuitous Lee I loved comics as a kid
that I lost interests as a teenager I
paid no attention whatsoever and but in
late in the late 60s I had several
friends who were into comics in fact I
lived right around here within ten
blocks of where we are right now and
they kind of reintroduced me to stuff
and Kim died Jim self I had gone to
college with and at Pratten into 62 to
64 and he had introduced me to winsor
mccay a little little nemo and crazy cat
i had never heard of them so that kind
of little time bomb went off six years
later in 1968 a friend of mine basically
goaded me to doing a comic and I was
soon as a filthy surreal piece of junk
but I took it down to screw I think it
was screw number three this was a sex
tabloid that at that point I didn't
realize I just thought it was an
underground paper I didn't buy so much
once again sex drugs it was all the same
so I brought my stripped down to the
offices of a screw which was I think it
was Al Goldstein's apartment on the
Upper West Side somewhere and Steve
Heller who later became the art director
for the New York Times Book Review and a
major book designer and major everything
I was the art director and he took one
look at my strip and he said you drew it
to the right proportions you're the
first one so it didn't really matter
what it was he just wanted to put an
implicit because it was correct tabloid
proportions yeah so but this this cover
here this is a this is the curt cover of
gothic blimp works number one the gothic
blimp works was a comic tabloids
spin-off of the East Village other and
there were that these were the venues
for comics when I was in New York in
those couple of years these village
other the gothic blimp and
screw later the New York ace but that
was a couple years later this I believe
Crump did this cover for something else
and they just used it because as you
could see it says jive comics I think
that was a cover for a comic he was he
was going to do that never actually
happened and this is number seven this
is robert williams who one of the zap
artists it was to this day of our
successful painter in LA the East
Village other was it was an alternative
underground newspaper but what what made
it commercially viable were the sex ads
in the back the classifieds this was
before the internet you know before
internet porn this this was the reason
these underground papers succeeded
because middle-class white men bought
them and took them home in the Long
Island Railroad and did what they did
with them and that was what made them
work the the the underground newspaper
distribution was mafia controlled they
were happy about this at all made sense
to them whenever anything like when the
gothic blimp came out it it only lasted
eight issues because it had no sex ads
it had it had just weird comics the
Mafia distributors were just puzzled and
befuddled by his and they gradually just
pulled it off the stands it probably
sold decently but not anywhere near the
amount of copies with the East Village
other was the numbers weren't sexy
enough know the numbers weren't sexy
enough so underground comics came in
went in New York in about a year and a
half when the blimp works was pulled
that put a chill on any idea of doing
comics for distribution in the city of
New York and so it was it was San
Francisco we all left we all took off
this is an early example this is an
early example of my work when I didn't
know what the hell I was doing
I still have this character mr. toad ooh
I I think I'm wedded to for life I
really like him and this is in the early
days when he was just out of control he
was just a raging it'd and you know I
wonder when when the editors of these
papers read these what they thought
because I wouldn't have printed this so
even if even at the time you wouldn't
refer did it I I mean I wasn't I wasn't
supporting the counterculture and I
wasn't a hippie really I was I probably
looked a little like a hippie but how
old were you how old was I twenty-four
twenty-three twenty-four twenty-five
yeah and um I mean I you know I got
stoned and I did the stuff that you did
but a lot of the comic artists around me
were doing with the exception I think I
mean Robert was really crumb was really
an exception in every way of course I
mean crumb crumb came into this world
fully blown fully fully formed at the
age of seven I mean literally he was
just a genius said from the beginning so
he's sooo a generous as they say there's
no nothing no one else like him but the
other cartoonists to one degree or
another win were doing their work
somewhat in support of the end of the
counterculture Kim deitch had a
character called sunshine girl sunshine
girl was basically tripping on acid and
Kim was using his acid experiences to
get storylines and people reading it got
that and that reinforced their idea that
if you take acid everything is beautiful
and well that's their high worked stoned
occasionally but not it never really
worked out for me it didn't it just
produced gibberish but not but but not
the right kind of gibberish Yeah right
well what am I saying by the king of
gibberish I control gibberish I I I
definitely use gibberish but I have a
little editor in my head that makes it
work somehow yes you have to have the
editor
okay and another east village will that
cover by Spiegelman here's here's Art
Spiegelman I had not met him at this
point when I went down to the offices of
these feather i met kim and i met Spain
who you may know that Spain Rodriguez
and I met Jake Kinney anybody know he is
but I never met art I didn't mean aren't
i went out to San Francisco he should
have met but we just didn't bump into
each other art was also doing stuff that
kind of was trippy as with this cover
although art was not a trippy person his
work did do some sort of reinforcing of
the counterculture I think and made
sense in that way and this is just the
typical issue at least happened to be
issues that I had lying around screw
later did comic covers in fact he did
many many comic covers but this is
before they got into comic covers and
the only kind of RT touches that that
wacky logo at the top which I remember
thinking was really cool laughing the
contents of screw were excruciating Lee
embarrassing to me i remember when i
looked at my first strip printed in i
just i folded all the paper behind I
don't want to see the rest of the paper
in relation to my comment not that I was
prudish it just seemed just like done a
dirty old man stubborn I mean you know
it's but within I would say two or three
weeks of doing my first trip I was
painting at this point i was living in
116 broadway I had a job at a book come
p on near columbus circle a french book
company was packing books and i painted
all day all night rather and when I saw
my first strip I asked Steve Heller how
many people are going to see this how
many copies do you print you said ten
thousand I said ten thousand i'm lucky
of ten people see my paintings forget
this and I ditched painting within
within sick
yes I was win six months anywhere from a
starving painter to a starving
cartoonist about that be a lesson yes
okay and I think this is the last one
here this is yeah it's a couple years
later when I came back to New York for a
visit this was the very beginning of
graffiti in the subways which at the
time I didn't you know I didn't think I
was doing anything historical but in
1972 71 72 graffiti in the subways was
actually just tagging done by gang
members and Taurik 161 was the main guy
he was everywhere and the other ones are
all real to magic Inca Greek and the
numbers below them are the streets the
streets on which they lived so I mean I
added I have towed doing his tag and as
if he is keeping an eye out for him
fruit left down the New York case lasted
a couple years it was it was a much
better paper I think in many ways than
the East Village other although less
culturally important maybe less of it
came along because papers like these
Filch other existed so it wasn't a
trailblazing paper but it had it had had
the better Steve Heller was also the art
director it had a great look and better
articles and it wasn't embarrassing to
look at it if the full that went over ok
and a bob we want to jump over to you
now Bobby give us some other images some
of some of things that you were in and
some things that you just thought were
important to talk about in this context
sure I and I had the great fortune to
work with Art Spiegelman in France was
muli at raw books which was their
company which was essentially them
working out of their loft and I worked
with him for many years and
it was it was the premier alternative
comic on the East Coast at least there
was weirdo on the west coast but but raw
was the place I wanted to be and I was
very lucky to work with them for a
number of years and Bill I know you were
in the first issues of raw too yep and
roars roar was a kind of an outgrowth of
arcade if people know arcade from the
70s that was the anthology art
spiegelman and I put a magazine together
called arcade for two years 75 to 76 and
then after a few years aren't left to go
back to New York and raw came so it's
kind of a genealogy there right right so
this is about ten years after arcade and
at this point the first volume of mouse
had come out so suddenly that
alternative comic book what is it
suddenly became a best-seller and that
allowed this collection of early earlier
issues of raw to be published by
pantheon so again the continuum from
working in the Underground's to
mainstream outlets continues mr. Rambis
same times it'd be started I guess
actually right you said 86 you started
from Sigma yeah yeah daily at the daily
so 80s when I just when I got out of
school comics were suddenly becoming hip
again and people were reading stuff and
all of those articles that you've read
comics aren't just for kids that was the
year they all came out in 1986 Wow jokes
the other oh I dropped these out just
because again in the 90s there were a
lot of outlets for comics in these two
publications a lot of my friends and
occasionally I would contribute it
strips to these new york press recently
passed on and the Village Voice which is
still going of course but they were a
home for a lot of people to create work
besides Pfeiffer and Stan Mac and Mark
Allen Stan MIDI and a few others they
the certain with the boys led in a lot
of new people and the press had an
amazing line-up when the
started in 1986 I think it was Mark new
garden has been catcher probably
forgetting a few mark buyer just amazing
group of alternative cartoonists finding
a home where they could create weekly
strips and sort of move closer to the
mainstream somehow and the New Yorker
Francois smoothly who you may remember
from two slides ago became the art
director for the covers of The New
Yorker in the early 90s and Robert Crum
is on the cover of The New Yorker so
from the east village other to the New
Yorker and again I suppose I said and
and the the cover on the on your mat
side is a one of mine which is
referencing Peter Arno or his classic
character from the 50s meeting a punk
from 1995 so it's the old new yorker in
the new New Yorker so another example of
alternative cartoonists getting their
way in and Bill you did a number of
great strips for The New Yorker yes
Franklin Tina Brown hijacked the new
yorker for a couple of years I was proud
to do some cartoon Oh journalism for
them yes yeah so Tina Brown was very
forward thinking and I just this is a
number of different anthologies that
I've contributed to these are
anthologies edited by cartoonists in New
York who also would reach beyond the
borders of New York but a lot of these
artists went to school at SVA were sort
of in the soup of all the alternative
cartooning seen here and went on to
create their own anthologies partially
inspired by raw partially inspired by
weirdo this is a recent one it's an
edited by Glen had this is a cover by
Michael kuperman that's a perfect this
covers a perfect example of cleansing
specialist wash and the bottom is it no
pics i should ask Michael it looks like
right
little bit yeah I think I had that issue
of poo it's very valuable oh and this is
a cover i drew for another anthology
edited by Danny Holman another mainstay
a mainstay of screw magazine for many
years as well as a Nilla straighter of
note and there is a real community here
I mean I came to the city because it in
the 80s it felt like a media capital I
really wanted to be part of that media
scene and even though a lot of my comics
end up parodying more successful
corporate characters I still love that
stuff and I've had a lot of
opportunities to work at big
organizations that New York recover i
showed you i didn't think that would be
a cover it was kind of a parody of the
New Yorker it ended up on the cover of
The New Yorker that kind of blew my mind
I did not I did not expect that to
happen it was submitted sort of as an
interior joke gag and it became the
cover and that almost made my head blow
up and oh this Landis yeah this is this
one kind of moving into the kind of the
community aspect of New York so yes
since you seem to be kind of one of
those hubs I directors I like to be a
hub yes I know a lot of I've been in New
York for over 20 years and I know a lot
of cartoonists and I love theater I done
a lot of performance art talk about
alternative art I love performance art
and I love theater and I began doing
these shows where we do cartoon readings
of our work and I started it when the
carousel slide projector was the means
by which to connect the artwork does
anyone remember slides you've probably
seen the episode of mad man that
explains in any case I've been doing
this show for over 10 years and I keep
trying to pull in more people and and
sort of get find another audience for
people who might not necessarily read
alternative comics but like stories with
funny pictures and julie has been in my
show and that leads us to Julia and
Julia sent me a couple pictures of you
in your studio and you're not alone in
your studio needs I won't if you can
talk a little bit about kind of like the
community that you feel yourself
part of now also in drinking at the
movies there's a lot of seems of you
sitting at diners or whatever with your
other cartoonist friends and stuff like
that you just maybe talk about the kind
of the car the the community at you kind
of feel that you're a part of right now
sure so I used to share a studio with us
five other female cartoonists it wasn't
on purpose that we're all female but
just it happened where's all friends
this is a bunch of other cartoonists who
Stephanie's visited who are just you may
be in that picture song um this is our
studio and we just have cartoonists over
we so draw together all once a week
where we get together so it's kind of
like there's this community of
cartoonists in Brooklyn that really is
unrivaled I think Portland has a hub of
a lot of cartoonists but um there's just
a lot in Brooklyn specifically and
there's a lot of us in Greenpoint so I
mean I guess that's what the community
looks like for New York yeah I obviously
did not understand the assignment so I
just said I just like look how fabulous
it is I have so many friends so there's
the work thing again I guess you know
what's interesting those these guys have
been showing slides of all the old
anthologies and newspapers and people
think that those aren't really around
anymore which isn't true and there's
smoke signals is one that gave Fowler
from desert island puts together that's
absolutely great I think we've all and
worked with him about that but he puts
together it's very much like the old
ones it's like a like an old fold-out
newspaper and it just has like really
weird comics to fairly normal comics
that would definitely be alternative if
you want to use that word a lot of
cartoonists now put together many comics
with a lot of other people's work in it
so definitely still happens it's just
sort of on a different level and I think
there's actually if there's a research
and Suffolk because there's a backlash
against I really know the word for not
like for like against big publishing
because it was they tried to to get a
bunch of indie cartoonist a couple years
ago and it didn't work out and there was
a
flash against it where the cartoonists
were like you know like I don't want to
work with big publishers because I
didn't have my back and now going back
to small press and doing stuff like that
like old magazine so it's kind of like
you know it started with really
alternative and then it he did huge arc
and we went to the other side and it was
awful so everyone's coming back to the
smaller circle where I think comics
really long right now since it is such a
you know a harder medium for people to
wrap their minds around right now but I
remember my mom got an issue of them I
think it's just that Sunday magazine in
The New Yorker and there was they'd put
a Chris we're like four-page spread and
they were starting a new thing they were
like you know comics this is new let's
put it in see how that the general
public likes him and my mom called me
and she was like truly I saw it I saw
cartoon it was four pages long and it
was in the New York Times she just never
seen one before likes your friend right
like not friends I wish I was no we're
not all friends it's not that small so
you know it's kind of it's going out
there but I think we're kind of
reclaiming it in a sense okay thanks and
wouldn't have to go through these uh
unfortunately the the individual strips
pretty quickly because I still have time
for Charles to talk also but bill gave
us a few stories a few zippy strips that
are kind of in New York and this is on
that you've already told this story well
this happen I already told you the story
so this is just my strip about getting
my first work published for Steve Heller
and screw and I'm saying the right
proportions I use New York a lot in my
strips i like i like to do architecture
i like i like old photos in the bottom
Zippy's under the third avenue el the
top I don't know if anybody knows who
crazy Guggenheim is that's a reference
to a character dental Jackie Gleason TV
show but yeah I San Francisco in New
York are my favorite cities and right
now New York above San Francisco I lived
in San Francisco 28 years and I think I
did it it's a great city but New Yorkers
where I'm from and I'll always come back
to it for material and this bottom
Serpas just agree
example of what I always tell people
that zippy has more art per square inch
than anything else in the newspaper it's
just phenomenal the top is Brooklyn as
if he goes time traveling to brooklyn in
1926 but he's humming a song from 1966
so go figure and he encounters Bob big
boy bob's big boy those are all from
photographs of old park slope and the
bottom is the that can you read what
station I think it's the Coney Island
stop Johnson no chance no spirit yeah
Chauncey street was another another
reference to the an old TV show but
there's zipping meeting the spirit body
of Alice Kramden and this one I don't
know just a lot of times my locations
come to me come to me in very dreamlike
ways and I had this kind of dream that I
was walking through Times Square I did
this while i was still in san francisco
i think so why I don't know why Times
Square but I like to place place either
zippy or my Griffey character in a
location that I just like to draw and
then have the stuff happen that's going
to happen it doesn't always relate to
the backgrounds what kind of reference
do you use well usually photographs
postcards have a huge collection of old
postcards and books books of New York
photos now I use Google a lot but yeah I
mean I i use reference and then i play
with it and toy with it hope it comes
out okay this is a sunday strip so okay
but
this was a this was actually a strip
that was commissioned by a big major
metropolitan magazine and got killed and
then it appeared in an alternative week
alternative anthology and this is just
this is an interesting example of my
work I guess because it's sort of
different than what I usually do these
are anecdotes about my life that
actually happened filtered through
different newspaper comics which is what
I always play with I don't usually use
myself as subject matter but in the
spirit of a panel about New York I
thought I should bring in especially the
one in the Kathy parity in the top where
someone's masturbating on the subway so
that's it seemed like a new york thing
to bring up sorry everybody columbia
this is a this is a recent this is a
recent piece not about New York but just
a strip I'm working on now I my stick
the stick on which I based my life is I
adapt the classics of western literature
in the style of famous cartoons
hopefully still famous in the 21st
century this is Homer's Popeye and yeah
it's sort of a six-page a six-panel
teaser for what will probably be a very
long story ultimately the classicist
will appreciate i am nobody in panel too
i just love that
Oh had this this is a this was done for
a long ago zine this is me trying to
find a way to like take what I'm
interested in and put it into you know
into a more mainstream publication so
this is me adapting a very New York
story 12 Angry Men in the you know using
superheroes mostly based in New York so
so there you go and I guess I apologize
to the to the US judicial system for
this okay now I got a couple pages from
Julia and I just chose a couple of them
were kind of like having kind of New
York moments like several New York
moments per page what's happening 00
some lady was shoplifting like bags and
nuts in one of those panels and everyone
was screaming code 99 and she was like
cloud me over and then I couldn't stop
laughing and they were like what's wrong
I don't even know what's going on I
don't know what I'm looking at the lower
east side they're shooting movies all
the time and I had my headphones on this
is a very like you know my generation
thing I had my headphones on there was a
paying attention and I walked right onto
the movie set and I didn't realize they
were all like yelling at me to not be
where I was to move my body and I was
like what's happening these are songs in
my head oh yeah when I first moved to
New York one of the things that i got
from another cartoonist a job was worth
doing set building for really fancy rich
people such as doing set building for
Sean Combs perfume release party it was
so ridiculous as you do yeah you know
Tuesday I had what sort of like to work
I guess in the middle of Manhattan I saw
their shooting sex in the city and I was
just kind of sitting right there hoping
I was in the background soils making a
really weird face awesome says on TV and
I didn't notice that but you're right
surgery Sarah Jessica Parker does kind
of look like a foot oh I hate that lines
I stole it from family guy and I don't
actually like that show and that's a
really mean thing to say so I apologize
and I want to turn it over to Charles a
little bit and Charles is going to talk
a little bit about again kind of the
repercussions of creating alternative
work right I think that one of the one
of the things that puts alternative and
put underground comics on the radar is
that they confront the established
boundaries of what's understood to be
acceptable culture and the underground
comics of the late 1960s were you know a
real revolution in that and the moat the
epicenter that revolution arguably was
AB comics which was founded by robert
crumb and went on to include
contributions from spain and escalade
Wilson and Victor moscoso and and others
and they were always a bit of a target
for for interest from the authorities
and so again the impulse of the
alternative cartoonists the underground
cartoonist is to speak in contrast to
the flow of how the world is going and
so zap doing that zapping very
confrontational and frank about
sexuality about drug use about the
hypocrisy of the culture was one of
those books that received a lot of
attention in a lot of intimidation where
police would go into stores and say you
better not be selling that on my beat
and so as bill mentioned there was a
period of time where the Underground's
were frequently getting busted where the
shopkeepers either
the head shops or the alternative
bookstores would be targeted and so on
the west coast you saw a lot of activity
where the iconic bookstore in Berkeley
Mo's was intimidated by police for
selling copies of snatch and copies of
zap the Berkeley Phoenix Art Gallery was
busted for display of obscene material
for a show of underground comics work
and there was even an arrest for zap
number two in Encino California so the
artists were formed by all of this they
were looking at the fact that people
were getting arrested people were
getting intimidated and you know they
basically went well it let's really
push the borders let's figure out you
know where we can take it and so zap
number four was deliberately designed to
be as provocative as possible and and
it's a great issue and it contains
probably the most controversial story
the one that was brought up most in
references during the arrest Robert
Crumb story Joe Blow which you see a
page from here jojo's the calmest page
I'm sorry I chose the calmest most a
tranquil page they're all tranquil pages
we're all adults it's an art but but Joe
Blow is a parody is a is a satire of the
gray flannel suit American family and
it's it's pointing out the hypocrisy zuv
the homogenous suburban culture that was
you know hey everybody go and hang out
with your family and do stuff you know
that was in the environment but crumb of
course took it to this extreme where he
was showing that here's this outside
facade look how happy they all are look
at this great house they all live in and
then behind closed doors they're having
an incest or g and the this really
raised the hackles of sensors because
they weren't looking at the artistic
merit they were looking at well all of
this stuff is for kids comic books are
for kids and they're putting dirty
pictures in this thing for kids you know
and this is alongside s clay wilson's
pirate rape orgies and viscera Victor
moscoso DH psychedelic
explorations and you know Spain's
revolutionary trash man comics and so
just in one package you know they really
put a live wire on the exposed nerve of
you know what was a culture war at the
time and this led to zap number for
being immediately targeted by police in
the West and in the east and in the East
is where the charge is stuck and so here
in New York of all places was really the
first time that you saw a conviction for
creating obscene comic books and it
would have been in 1970 that the book
dealers Peter Dargis who managed the
east side bookshop and Charles
Kirkpatrick who was the co-manager of
The New Yorker bookshop were arrested
for selling this comic book and were
charged with the distribution of obscene
material they were defended by an
attorney named Robert Levine who
litigated I think a very persuasive
defense he had Gil Kane who was the
cartoonist that contributed to a lot of
classic marvel and DC comics of the era
robert m dory who is the curator of the
whitney museum of art stephen Marquez
who was actually a professor here at
Columbia and worked in youth education
and sip Jacobson who was the publisher
of Harvey comics and they went on the
stand to discuss and describe the
redeeming artistic merit in this work
and to describe that what crumb was
doing which is where people were fixated
possessed important artistic and
cultural value but they were seated they
were they're being heard by a judge
named Joel Tyler who was a moral
crusader who later went on to view and
subsequently banned the movie deep
throat in the mid 70s so he was
extremely dismissive of the expert
testimony you know saying to the
Columbia professor you just can't get
past the fact that your professor can
you when he's describing in academic
terms the merit of these comics when
Jacobson was on the stand and was
talking about the fact that comics do
address sexuality
and used Archie as an example the judge
was completely shocked are you saying
Archie's have seen no Archie is designed
to discuss and and stir sexual impulses
in adolescents because this is what
they're feeling anyway you know you can
read this in the transcript he was
describing the work that he was
publishing it Harvey is you know design
for the youngest of readers and the
judge goes I take obsession to that I
read your comic books all the time so
this is the guy that's deciding the fate
of underground comic books and easily as
you can predict from you know that kind
of taste and that kind of dismissiveness
of the expert testimony he convicted and
so an appeal was waged and there were
amicus briefs or friend of the court
documents submitted by the Association
of American publishers and the New York
Civil Liberties Union espousing the
First Amendment merit of the case and
the only real leg they had to overturn
it was a provision in New York law at
the time that said that to be convicted
of distributing or promoting obscene
material you needed to be you had to do
it knowingly and so there was an
argument that it would be impossible for
the clerk to knowingly possess you know
awareness of everything in the shop and
ultimately where it came down is well if
he has displayed it you should have
known and as the defendant said
afterwards after the conviction was
upheld in a four-to-three verdict that
this means that you've got to make us
chicken about work you've got to make a
sensor the stuff that comes into the
store and so that in concert with the
1973 decision in the Miller test were
effectively the twin punches that
knocked out the underground comix
economy where the Underground's were
being traded in this national network of
head shops and sophisticated bookstores
and when it became a a local issue that
your local community can determine
what's obscene there was a general sense
that I'm told from people that were
there of well jeez you know if a New
York if they busted a comic in New York
and got a conviction
what chance do I have in sheboygan you
know in a shop selling bonds that
they're already looking to scan SAT and
so as Dennis kitchen told me there was a
period where Tyler Lancey his sales
manager was charting 1973 sales and 72
the trend was like this 73 down down
down down and he actually took the
sharpie or whatever it was at the time
and took it off the wall and sort of
drawing off of the paper and onto the
wall it was plummeting to the floor and
it almost killed the thing and yet as
this panel is evidence art thrives and
survives and art continues to provoke
and art continues to push the limits and
you saw that here in the New York again
with the raw moment that was purring the
notion of you know comics as low culture
and also world war three Illustrated
which was taking up the mantle of the
punk sensibility and espousing it in
very confrontational terms at a time
that we needed it you know during the
Reagan era where you know there was a
lot of speech you know that was like the
Plasmatics you know here in New York you
know making very pointed political art
and today just by way of you know
conclusion we're seeing another moment
where you know I think we're at the cusp
of the clamp down on corporates going
after people like Bob sorry Bob that are
using corporately controlled work is
commentary you know and you're starting
to see this notion that's emerging in
the halls of Disney and Warner Brothers
but the people at Marvel and DC don't
want to want to attack but you're seeing
this notion emerging that any use of a
drawing that is a trademark character
that is not authorized is an
infringement and so you know I'm
starting to see more artists come to me
at the comic book Legal Defense Fund
which is an organization that protects
the First Amendment rights of comics and
say I just got this odious cease and
desist letter that's saying that I need
to turn over all of my original arts and
you know everything that I've ever sold
and all the money I've ever made and any
children I ever
you know we get because I drew a strip
that juxtaposes tubby and you know
Jarvis or whatever the case might be so
you know it's never authorized to make
and a reproduction you know of somebody
else's work but now you know what's been
established as you know understood since
you know Andy Warhol that you can make a
one-of-a-kind artistic piece or you can
make a comment using corporate marks
that is now you know something that's
being challenged and I think that's you
know going to be litigated in their
future so the job of the underground and
the alternative cartoonist is to always
speak truth to power and speak to the
boundaries of of society and and and
they do it not for a lot of money which
is why communities like New York are so
important because the bonhomie that
emerges when you're working with
like-minded people advances the art and
creates its own kind of reward structure
for doing it and there's always going to
be moments where we're living high on
the hog and we're getting big advances
from publishers and it's gonna be
moments where they drop us like a lead
potato and decide they don't want our
work and it's the communities here that
hold up each other's work that advance
the art form and its communities that
support people that you know to support
the work of the comic legal defense fund
organizations like this that make sure
the law can't stamp us down permanently
thank
we got time for a couple of questions if
anybody wants to step up to the mic over
here class so there's been some 20 what
am i waiting okay all right great so you
guys have kind of been talking about
some mention of sort of how the age of
these anthologies have sort of passed
and there are some mentions on the
Internet so I've been kind of thinking
wondering with the internet we sort of
have this new avenue to have a lot like
smaller works independent artist putting
their work out there do you think that
that is sort of opened up an avenue for
the continuation of alternative comics
and underground comics or has it sort of
diluted their commentary power in their
texture like how does it kind of effect
alternative comics I think it's given
people more outlets but I don't think
it's squelched anything I i if I
understand your question it sounds as if
it's just it's just the latest outlet
for people I don't think it actually has
hurt anything except maybe our ability
to get paid but I'm I'm excited about
online publishing I could probably into
this one since I'm of that generation I
I don't think like you I don't think it
squelches but I also don't think it
really raises anything because anyone
can put something online but if you put
something online say like this is the
achievement you know you can put
something online but you if your work
isn't good you're not going to go any
higher no one else is going to really
see it your work has to be good enough
to excel beyond just putting your
on the internet like you you know and if
the work isn't there this that's just
going to stay on the internet so I don't
really think that expands or tracks will
really affects anything of the whole I'm
sorry gonna follow
sorry my problems um I guess one of the
elements I guess referring to kind of
the squirrel Qing is more of the
community aspect I mean he referred to
the fact that a lot of the strength of
comics today of like these underground
comic today is in there the ability for
the community to kind of uphold other
artists and that sort of thing and I
feel like that's how it was with the
older anthologies you you know you guys
reference other artists that you worked
really closely with so do you feel like
the I mean I guess the internet makes
each artist more independent do you
think online communities are not as
potent like support structures for you
know get like support in New York that's
actually variable because here in New
York you had the activate collective
that happened in the early 2000s through
the mid-2000s you know that was
explicitly about the creation of work to
be distributed online and it functioned
as a you know a fully fledged anthology
and you know now there was all of the
usual and fighting that you get from
groups of artists and it dissolved and
now there's a new group doing it so I
think that you know the community
impulse to publish is as strong anywhere
and you know I think that as Julia said
it's neither additive nor subtractive
artists are going to do work and they're
going to get it out there as best they
can afford next question this is mostly
in Charles's wheelhouse but kind of
speaks to everybody um I thought maybe
you discuss SOPA a little bit I don't
really have anything to say about sopa
and I was like how it affects yeah is
there are their communities you're aware
of or things that we're doing as a
community of artists that are engaging
that and talking about why we need to
survive SOPA I think that you know eff
did a good job managing it and I think
that you know the way all of these laws
work is that didn't get past this time
and they're going to try to pass it you
know together next time and you know
that's not really our wheelhouse you
know we protect the First Amendment as
effects artist but I think it's just a
matter of using art a civic engagement
and you know communicating that Bob you
can help me take this more it's bad yeah
I I don't have anything to add to it I'm
sorry I just I was just being smarmy or
snarky okay one last question what I'm
really burning to know and Julia touched
on it a little bit is what did or what
do your moms think about what you do my
mother had a zippy tattoo on the back my
mom was always very supportive of my
work but if you can appear in The New
Yorker that kind of raises the that
raises the level of appreciation that's
all I have to say my mom is actually a
wee I grew up reading your comic and my
mom was the first one who showed it to
me too so she's probably a bigger fan of
you then she's of me my mom likes it
she's always like I'm so funny put me in
a comic I'm so clever that's cool a
supportive supportive is a good way to
end the panel if we could just thank our
panelists once again
you